to all our wonderful teachers thank you
for everything you do good luck in turn
two and please be reassured we will
never take you for granted ever again
this is just a quick message to all the
teachers out there heading into term - I
know you're being asked to go above and
beyond thank you so much for what you do
stay safe and remember - all the
teachers out there on behalf of everyone
at the Public Education Foundation
thanks for your amazing efforts helping
us adapt so far good luck is he going to
turn to stay safe stay well
teachers Rock - all the teachers out
there I know you haven't ever stopped
teaching through Kovan but it's a night
before term - and you're all back in
school tomorrow so I wanted to say all
the very best for term - thank you for
everything you've been doing across the
education system and stay safe teachers
it's the night before term - the night
before the first day back it's always
hard but especially now just thinking of
you my mum was a teacher
secondary tertiary for over 40 years I
feel your pain so just thinking of you
I just want to stamp something on your
behalf or maybe just you know correct
something but instead I'm gonna go out
I'm gonna pick up 50 papers you need by
school teachers Rock hello this is John
Bell with a word of encouragement to all
of our teachers there were doing such a
wonderful job are the most difficult and
confusing of circumstances you hold the
key to our future and we deeply
appreciate your courage and commitment
thank you again for all you're doing for
being one of our only certainties in
such uncertain times and for always
caring about our kids no matter what is
thrown at you to all the teachers thank
you and for whatever turn to
is going to look like good luck but we
know that you'll continue to shop every
day and you'll change lives
you're the lives and big lives because
that's what teachers do and that's why
we love you and that is definitely why
teachers rock good a how you're going
Adam Spencer here as a citizen of the
great state of New South Wales I know
tomorrow in this state term two begins a
term of initially isolated then semi
isolated then not isolated learning I
think I don't really understand one
thing I do understand teachers Rock have
a great turn teachers hey it's you miss
teens here and I just wanted to send a
shout out to teachers thanks for all the
hard work you do the parent of four
school-age kids - in primary - in high
school one of those is in your 12 and I
really see the work that you do and for
every one of my four kids there's always
at least one teacher that helps connect
them to their education inspires them
somebody they want to please and excite
and it makes such a difference to their
learning so big thank you we know it's
an absolute [ __ ] show for you and we
appreciate the work you do so much
always been a fan just jumping on the
positivity of the teachers Rock hashtag
you really don't what I'm saying over
the last few weeks has been absolutely
amazing my hair may be turning more ray
Martin by the day but we need what you
are doing far more than I need a haircut
it's been remarkable and at the same
time wholly unsurprising tailored so
that all the New South Wales see was
heading back tomorrow
all the teachers around the country that
have already headed back or awaiting for
that
I'm thoroughly impressed about good luck
in term 2 thanks for all the hard work
as a parent I appreciate everything that
you guys do for our community it's you
guys are the heart and soul so you rock
teachers Rock good luck they say hey
folks so as any Australian teacher
parent or student knows term 2 starts
tomorrow
in fact the Queenslanders territory ins
and Victorians it's already started and
because every good asian kid loves their
teacher in fact we'd die for our teacher
it's a cultural thing I just wanted to
give a shout out to all the teachers and
support staff during this especially
stressful time your hard work and
indefatigable tech and logistics
wrangling in this really stressful time
does not go unacknowledged so stay safe
and same or as much as you can being a
teacher and thanks for doing your job
hi on the eve of term 2 I just want to
wish teachers all the very best for the
new term and just say how grateful I am
for all the hard work you've been doing
I know how hard it's been out Dave it's
been and I just want to say we really
appreciate it
we see what you do thanks very much and
teachers Rock hi there Denise Scott
speaking and recently on 7:30 report
they've been showing videos of teachers
sending messages of love and
appreciation to their students and I
full-on have bawled my eyes out every
time I've watched them
so look teachers whether you're zooming
whether you're skyping whether you're
Webb Xing whether you're teaching and
you're wearing your pajamas in your
kitchen or whether you're teaching
face-to-face in a classroom please
understand that all us mere mortal aziz
think you teachers are the greatest and
we respect every one of you well except
for that mrs. Brown who taught me but
that was 1961 and I don't think she was
very well good luck teachers we love you
to all my fellow teachers in New South
Wales who are about to head back for
term two I want to say it's been such a
crazy you were already with the fires
and now covered 19 and it's in such a
struggle for all of us to adapt
changing needs of our students as we
struggle to help them continue learning
I just want you all to remember your
work and your effort and your time means
so much to the communities that you
serve so stay safe look after yourselves
and remember you're making a huge impact
positively for the people in your
schools take care guys
hi I'm Tracey Spicer
and I come from a long line of teachers
I can only imagine how incredibly
difficult it's been for you all this
year so far and we've turned to about to
come up I just wanted you to know that
you are honored you are respected and
yes you are loved we all know that
education is the pathway out of poverty
and the work you do is not only
life-changing it is life-saving so thank
you
teachers Rock
to all the teachers out there thank you
for every single thing you do every
single day I know you've given up so
much you always to prepare for tomorrow
we're with you all of the way and I've
got to say having walked a mile in your
shoes I know exactly how important a
role it is so let's just say this and I
know it's shared across Australia
teachers Rock good luck tomorrow
thank you for going above and beyond all
of the time
to our teachers all around Australia as
we head into the new term thank you and
please know that you're in our thoughts
and we appreciate everything that you do
hey guys sentry starts tomorrow here in
New South Wales and you know what it's
this is like nothing we've ever seen
before with coronavirus and having to do
with students and children of essential
workers and vulnerable children who need
to be at school as well as kids who need
to still serve isolate for who knows how
much longer so I just want to take this
moment to just give a shout out to all
the teachers out there thank you so much
you have gone above and beyond not just
for my kids but for everybody's kids so
you you've been online you've been
assisting where you can letting us
parents you know message you and text
you and say are we doing it right and
helping us through it you really have
been right on the front line for our
families here
so as term true begins and whatever term
to brings I just wanted to say thank you
guys so so much
stay safe and let's all work together
this term to teachers you rock hello
Paul Keating here possibly the greatest
Education Minister this country never
had but I would just like to add my
voice of support to all the fantastic
teachers of Australia doing an
extraordinary job frontline workers
clean it up
if he bored he screamed when will passed
the teacher and they thought they must
have dreamed when we passed the teacher
because you just can't do that at the
moment because of cold that you
shouldn't really do it anyway but I want
to hug him but you really can't do that
either but just what I say
teachers Rock